et aujourd'hui en fin d'après-midi à
lagence de votre confrère le midi rubin
ap yade en présence des représentants de
la municipalité
les accordailles officielle entre le
club et les nouvelles recrues ont été
rendues officielles ces recrues les
voici
flory un dinallo plusieurs fois
international henri roger l'ex-capitaine
du nîmes olympique et le montpelliérain
georges calmettes qui après ajaccio et
bastia revient dans son pays
messieurs les présidents fleury di nallo
georges calmettes henry aurait pour un
petit club petit club de 3e division
ça me semble beaucoup pourquoi je pense
qu'il fallait redonner sa place au
football à montpellier et si nous avons
fait venir ces trois joueurs au club de
la paillade c'est que nous avons de
grands espoirs pour la future saison et
j'espère que le public viendra nombreux
d encourager pour gravir les échelons et
rob est remonté montpellier en première
division
bien vous pensez toujours à des
escaliers qui montent ce pas alors vous
partie et d'assez bas et où voulez-vous
la grille très haut et eau pour vous
pensent auxerre premièrement cette année
essayer de faire une bonne carrière en
coupe de france est monté bien sûr en
troisième division et ensuite ça sera
peur ça sera jusqu'en haut
jusqu'à la première division est ce que
l'on peut considérer puisque c'est un
coup d'envoi aujourd'hui parce que le
fils y est oui que ce n'est qu'un départ
est que nous aurons d'autres surprises
de toute manière la yann ce qu'il peut
le secret des lieux nous travaillons en
profondeur tant que projet mais on
prépare surtout l'avenir de nos jeunes
parce que en définitive si on a recruté
fortement cette année c'est aussi pour
préparer la place de no2 neuneu
pailladins gay montpelliéraine pour la
votre avis bon ben là on départ de cette
saison on peut dire que la paillade
s'est bien porté l'année dernière et que
vous avez l'intention avec les efforts
que vous faites qu'elles se sentent
encore apg nous étions pratiquement
certaine
[Musique]